I said to blood work two liver enzymes went down, so that's a good side, but the alkaline phosphate went up a lot. So let's think about that a little bit.
So elevated liver enzymes almost invariably speak to damage to the liver via, you know, toxin exposure or the tasticist to the liver.
Alkaline phosphate alkaline phosphatase is considered a liver enzyme, but it also will elevate, so it'll elevate if there's damage to the liver, but it will also go up if there's metastasis to the bone, which your other liver enzymes won't.
So if you have normal liver enzymes with elevated alkaline phosphatase, then you think of is there metastasis to the bone. So in this case, if your liver enzymes went down, that means we're detoxing much better.
If your alkaline phosphate alkaline phosphatase went up, that just as an indication of what we already know in this person's cases that there's metastasis to the bone doesn't mean that there's more, more metastasis per se, but that's why it's going up.
Trying to do as many copy animals as possible today, and that's what's probably helping detox the liver and helping with the, with the liver enzymes, casserole packs, lung with everything else started radiation on Monday on rip any ideas.
I did start healabores, mistletoe last week, just half the dose. So understand there's two different types of mistletoe that is used in mistletoe therapy.
The healabores is the second type that can be very beneficial if the person's doing radiation.
So I'm glad that your doctor is doing well with that.
I'm not sure if the alkaline phosphatase went up after the radiation or not. It's going to be interesting to see how radiation therapy changes the alkaline phosphatase levels.